What about these? These look beige-y to you?
Sorry.
I'm his trainer, so it's kind of the house that
coach built right here.
What are we looking at here? That's Baby
Smooth.
This is LLS.
Ladies love Schmidt.
What? What did you just say?
Go put a dollar in the jar right now.
Are you serious?
Yeah. Now.
Damn it.
Who's that girl?
It's Jess.
Please put your shirt back on. Please don't
make me laugh at you.
Can I hit you up with some tea? A little herb
tea. Oh. Oh, my God.
How good is that? For real. What? Little
p-man tea? Yum.
Right? Hot, sweet... Little tea bag action.
And I wasn't... I wasn't talking about.
There it is.
Douche bag.
Oh, Jess, I just found a Groupon for hypnosis
lessons. Think about what you can do with that.
Sex stuff.
Jar.
Look, guys, has anyone seen my good pea coat?
Jar!
Have you seen my sharkskin laptop sleeve?
Darn it.
Has anyone seen my croquet cleats?
Hey, Jess, have you seen my other timepiece?
Nick, I came up with the best name for an
uncircumcised penis.
Bishop in a turtleneck!
Jar!
Damn it, I can't find my driving moccasins anywhere!
Jess, are you cooking a frittata in a
saucepan? What is this, prison?
Jar. That's a jar for sure.
I know, I already got the money ready.
Sadie, before you leave, can I just ask you a few questions?
I know where this is going.
You are a gynecologist and a lesbian, which
makes you, well, a va-genius.
Jar
I know my way around a Grizzly Adams.
You too? Jar.
As an adult male, I would like to ask you a
few questions about, you know, the downstairs girl cookie.
jars.
Jars all around jar.
Well, the only thing he left was my summer
suit with a lightning bolt on the back.
I keep that in my summer bin along with my
summer condoms.
Citrus flavored for more refreshing summer experience.
That's a jar.
Jar for sure. Yeah.
You remember this?
It looks like it's finally just the two of
us, huh?
Oh, God. You're about to say something
stupid, aren't you?
Girl, I'm a marry you.
Jar.
I know this might seem crazy and... probably a
little bit impulsive, but it's not.
Not for me.
I've known since the minute that I met you.
Oh, my God.
Cecilia Parekh...
Oh, God. You're going to say something
stupid, aren't you?
Girl, will you marry me?
Oh.
Would you please shut up? I can't hear the
answer.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Yes. Woo hoo!
We're getting married!